here's a heartwarming story of family
and politics
not really Kevin Nicholson is a 40 year
old with Wisconsin Republican he wants
to challenge incumbent senator Tammy
Baldwin Tammy Baldwin is a Democrat
Kevin Nicholson's parents have decided
to make the maximum allowable political
donation not to him but to his possible
eventual opponent current senator Tammy
Baldwin interestingly Kevin Nicholson
used to be a Democrat but he turned into
a Republican and he was asked about this
situation where his parents are
supporting his possible opponent and he
said quote I'm a conservative today not
because I was born one but because of
the experience
I earned as a marine in combat my
experience as a husband and father my
choice to be a Christian the schools I
chose to attend and the decision to
pursue the career I have so it's not
clear he's going to win the Republican
primary yet we'll have to see he did get
an endorsement from a Stephen ban and
backed PAC and he has also been
supported by vile disgusting depraved
and delusional Texas senator Ted Cruz so
he has that going for him at least when
you're backed by to hook what would we
call him poster boys for the defy
gravity of the current Republican Party
it doesn't say particularly good things
about you and his stated reasons for
switching from being a Democrat early in
life to a Republican are his
participation in the Iraq war and his
newfound Christian beliefs that he's
chosen I actually kind of feel bad for
this guy and the world seems to have so
confused him that he doesn't seem to
know where up is what's up and what's
down at this point and we've talked
about producer Pat's awkward
Thanksgiving meals with the conservative
side of his family imagine this right he
I can't even imagine what this would be
like at Thanksgiving I do have a lot of
right-wingers in my family but I have to
imagine that if I ran for political
office they would still support me and
if they chose not to support me they
probably would keep quiet about it or at
least not donate to my political
opponent right there are people that are
saying David this is no big deal
families have different politics it's
being blown out of
yeah I mean you know politics very and
Families Pat's family is an example
sometimes it's shades of gray sometimes
it's black and white but there's a major
difference between not actively
supporting your son's candidacy to the
complete other side which is actively
donating the maximum allowed by law to
the person that your son would be
running against and with everything now
there's conspiracy theories and the one
here is that Nicholson is not really a
Republican right like he did a fake
conversion to being a Republican in
order to do something I don't know what
and then after this if he wins he would
turn back to being a Democrat or
something like I don't even know the
logic of the conspiracy but there is a
conspiracy theory out there yeah I think
the more reasonable conspiracy theory
would be that there's something in
Nicholson's past defending his parents
from supporting him not just his
politics alone right like you know maybe
there's something sketchy going on with
him but like he early speculation like
he committed like there's some kind of
family drama something horrible he did
in the family and is not a good person
oh okay well he doesn't sound like the
best person to me already just based on
what's public but what we can my
conclusion here is good luck to Tammy
Baldwin in this race that's that's where
I am on this thing but family drama I
wouldn't want to be there he should
listen to his mom I have no qualms with
saying that I I have no problem with
people being momma's boys' I think that
that's great and he should actually
listen to his mom when it comes to
politics the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad